between the dragon ball super manga goku
jumping off the battle bus and fortnite
and the release of dragon ball super
superhero it's a good time to love
dragon ball how goes it everyone i'm red
muffler man since rob's hibernating in
the sand healing chamber after staying
up all night to watch she-hulk i'll be
the one talking about dragon ball super
superhero giving my general thoughts on
it and covering any small details you
might have missed along the way so let's
get into it to start with the movie
opens up with this gorgeous hand-drawn
animated set piece running down the
origin of the red ribbon army who were
one of the main baddies in the original
dragon ball showing characters who
haven't been drawn in a modern dragon
ball style for a very long time
commander blue officer black and even
smaller bit characters like android 8.
they even show goku blowing up mercenary
tao the intro also briefly goes over the
events of the android saga the death of
dr ghetto and of course the birth of
cell and seeing cell drawn in the modern
dragon ball style was honestly a real
treat for me especially since both
toriyama and toei have gone on records
saying they go out of their way to not
draw cell anymore because his spots make
him way too difficult to draw
consistently so yeah if you've ever
wondered why frieza was allowed to come
back and not sell well there's your
answer but from here we're introduced to
our uh big baddie magenta the son of
commander rad who is in charge of the
red ribbon army back in dragon ball and
much like his father he wants to bring
the army back into prominence and like
everyone else in the red ribbon army he
is named after a color god i love
toriyama naming conventions goku
literally named his son food and then we
have dr heto the grandson of dr ghetto
and i love this dude fun fact dr heto's
name is meant to be a play on words for
nausea medication while dr ghetto's name
essentially translates to dr vomit but
his name isn't the only thing that's the
polar opposite of his granddad while
ghetto wanted to build androids for the
purpose of world domination pedo is just
a sweet lovable little dork that wants
to make android superheroes he also
stole some corpses to go toward that
research but uh you know who isn't a
little problematic these days magenta
meets with hedo to try to get his
android expertise on his side but at
this point hedo isn't convinced since
working with the red ribbon army isn't
exactly something superman would do so
magenta shows him a video a video
that'll look really familiar to dragon
ball fans it's a candid shot of the
scene where future trunks eviscerates
frieza in real time and i
giggled when i saw this obviously the
original scene had all the flair and
slow pacing you'd expect from old dragon
ball z but seeing trunks just hop up to
frieza and cut him up like fresh sashimi
in two seconds was a really cathartic
way to reframe that scene but yeah the
video convinces heto that the people
running around capsule corporation are
like lizard people or something and he's
like yeah that's good enough of a reason
for me to build super robots for
fascists and from here we move on to
piccolo who's gotten a bit of a design
change his arms have gone from bright
pink to yellow this is because of the
fact that as namekians get older the
color of their uh
arm sacks
began to change so he did it everybody
piccolo finally hit puberty not only
that he's a homeowner has a cell phone
and his bed is covered in a mountain of
plushies he's just like me for real for
real but we see that he's training pan
right now who at this point is three
meaning this movie is placed about a
year off from the end of dragon ball z
where goku just goes off to train with
ub leaving his family behind for like a
decade granted it's not like goku is a
stranger to just leaving his family and
friends for long stretches of time for
shadowing but shortly after this we're
introduced to gamma one and gamma two
these guys are androids and they're the
magnum opus creations of dr hetto as
mentioned earlier hedo's entire
aesthetic is based around superheroes
heroes of justice all that cool and
these guys are all that and more gamma 1
and gamma 2 follow the hero aesthetics
found in tokusatsu and super sentai
shows basically the japanese power
rangers the duo are constantly striking
powerful hero poses with pyrotechnics in
the back as onomatopoeia appear behind
them the words actually appear and
piccolo at one point is even in shock
because of it this is seemingly
explained through the fact that hedo in
order to make his androids as cool as
possible built hologram generators into
their backs the fact that he was this
much of a dork to include this solely
because he watched a lot of power
rangers as a kid is incredible but gamma
1 and gamma 2's relation to tokusatsu
doesn't end there their characterization
even follows a standard formula found in
the genre of super sentai gamma 1 is
level-headed and stoic he acts logically
with the responsibility of a leader
essentially the red ranger meanwhile
gamma 2 acts in the opposite fashion
cracking puns at a moment's notice
living relatively carefree but also
being prone to lashing out in bouts of
emotion many of which are traits found
in secondary rangers the two androids
fight with toyish laser blasters they
fly around with flashy high impact moves
like the inazuma kick or straight up
drop kicking people they are the living
embodiment of the japanese live-action
superhero aesthetic and i love it and
another thing about this movie is that
it really plays with a lot of the tropes
people are used to with dragon ball as a
whole so these gamma androids are real
strong and they're up to no good right
well nothing goku and vegeta can't
handle right well throughout the entire
movie goku vegeta and broly are training
up on the planet of lord beerus while
everyone else there just eats ice cream
and they end up missing all of bulma's
phone calls trying to get goku and
vegeta back to earth this is so
relatable i miss work phone calls like
all the time well that's fine though
since bulma is the dragon ball so they
can just wish away the red ribbon army
right well no because piccolo is petty
and that's an easy way out so instead he
just wishes for the dragon to give him
an awakening of his hidden power akin to
the one gohan and krillin received from
guru then bulma wishes for a toned ass
and longer eyelashes but then realized
they could have just used the dragon
balls to teleport goku and vegeta there
instead this is the kind of slapstick
playing with your expectations that i
expect from classic dragon ball the kind
of story where krillin wins a fight by
farting in a dude's face or oolong
wishing for a pair of underwear i'm
honestly a huge fan of this whimsical
approach to the writing it's very
toriyama then we have gohan and the
first thing i gotta say is this dude
finally found a barber gohan's hair in
super looks so
bad
but gohan's hair isn't the only glow up
this movie overall feels like the send
up to his character that we were
promised during the buu saga gohan
begins the movie soft and out of
practice similar to how he was the
beginning of super but after pan gets
kidnapped weird see gohan get mad and he
and piccolo take the fight to the red
ribbon army and it's here that piccolo
after like 30 years it's a new form
piccolo orange no oh yeah that's orange
alright jokes aside i'm actually a big
fan of this transformation visually it
takes a combination of elements from
piccolo's normal design and gives them
the more chiseled demonic look of king
piccolo his antenna are framed on his
face in such a way that they come off
more as devil horns hearkening back to
his origin in the original dragon ball
as a demon king while he's in this form
they even throw back to piccolo's
ability to grow in size to gigantic
proportions which he used against goku
in the world martial arts tournament but
now moving on to the climax the film's
big reveals that while dr hetto had
built gamma 1 and gamma 2 he was also
forced to produce cell max a successor
to the original cell created by dr
ghetto while the androids are fighting
with gohan and piccolo cell max ends up
getting woken up and this results in
piccolo gohan the gammas and basically
every b-less dragon ball character
trying to stop him and this leads to
something very interesting i noticed
about gamma one and two gamma one and
two are red and blue respectively and on
one hand thematically that is to tie
into the superhero toku aesthetic but
this also likely ties into the japanese
folk legend of the red and blue oni the
story goes that there was once a red oni
who wished to make friends with a
village of humans however the village
shunned him and wanted nothing to do
with the demon the red oni also had his
best friend the blue oni hearing of the
red onis plight the blue only offers to
faint attacking the village in order for
the red oni to step in and stop him in
order to look like a hero to the
villagers the plant succeeds but the red
oni then realizes he can never speak to
the blue oni again lest the villagers
learn that it was a scheme in essence
blue sacrifices himself for red's
happiness and here against cell
gamma 2 sacrifices his life to fatally
weaken cell max and potentially allow
gamma 1 the opportunity to be a hero to
those around him and to seek redemption
this central theme between gamma 1 and 2
is honestly my favorite part of this
entire film and i hope we get to see
more of gamma 1 later on in dragon ball
super's continuation finally we have
gohan's new transformation called gohan
beast they literally made gohan blanco
cannon god also
why is his hair so tall
what the [ __ ]
okay jokes aside this [ __ ] is raw in the
scene where gohan achieves this
transformation it's meant to mirror the
scene where gohan achieved super saiyan
2 against cell after the death of
android 16 shot for shot they recreated
complete with the reflection in gohan's
eyes the red line indicating the snap
gohan's explosion when this happened my
theater went crazy i went crazy gohan is
furious and his design mirrors the super
saiyan 2 design which is such a cool
detail and to top it all off to finish
off cell max he doesn't use the
kamehameha no no no no he uses the
special beam cannon thematically this is
gohan separating himself from his father
and if you look at the context of how
he's been treated in dragon ball in
terms of giving up his spotlight to goku
it's a special kind of cathartic but i
also think the scene solidifies the
respect between piccolo and gohan that
when things were at their worst gohan
chose to use piccolo's technique that
goku may be his father but piccolo is
his master and with that i think i've
rambled long enough here dragon ball
super superhero is a fantastic movie and
i had a blast getting to go on about it
as per usual if you like what we do feel
free to drop a comment hit like and
subscribe to the channel and if you like
me you can follow me on twitch twitter
and youtube at red muffler man and yeah
have a good one everybody take it easy
oh yeah and vegeta be goku in the
sparring match so i guess vegeta is
canonically stronger
i'm the [ __ ] best kakarot